le nazisme a gâché ma jeunesse
déclarations du pape à new york qui a
exhorté les jeunes américains ne pas
croire que le mal a disparu avec la fin
de la deuxième guerre mondiale
il peut reçu jeu se re surgir sous
diverses formes at il dit benoît 16 qui
s'est recueillie tout à l'heure sur le
fameux ground zero là où se trouvaient
les tours jumelles avant l'attentât du
11 septembre 2001 sur place martine
laroche-joubert pascal geoffrion
le pape benoît 16 découvre ce matin le
site de ground zero
trois mille personnes ont péri ici lors
des attentats du 11 septembre 2001 c'est
la première visite d'un pape
l'occasion pour les familles des
victimes d'entendre des paroles de
réconfort une solennité une gravité à
l'image du ciel gris et brumeux tout en
contraste avec la joyeuse parade est
ouvert sur la santé même quelques
précisions
éclatante sous le soleil
ali nulle part la joie des fidèles une
étape de gaieté au cours d'un séjour
marqué par la volonté du pape d'aborder
des sujets sensibles
après les abus sexuels des prêtres
pédophiles benoît 16 évoque sur le
campus de séminaire saint joseph ont
passé enrôlés de force dans les
jeunesses hitlériennes mais années
d'adolescence ont été dévastées par un
régime sinistre se pensaient détenir
toutes les réponses son influence a
grandi dans les écoles les structures de
la société la politique et même la
religion avant d'être pleinement
reconnue pour le monstre qu'ils étaient
deux doigts 16 s'apprête à célébrer une
messe ici au yankee stadium
des milliers de fidèles l'attend déjà